et là donc il y a quoi
une prochainement des carottes sur cette
parcelle aurait dû pousser aubergines
courgettes et autres tomates à l'abri
d'une serre mais le 13 avril les aléas
climatiques ont contraint les frères
Joseph à revoir leur plan il a plus 30
mm à peu près pendant 10 jours avant et
le soir le soir du 13 au 14 il y a du il
y a dû avoir beaucoup de vent et on a
une mini tornade qui a dû se prendre un
petit peu sous la sous la serre elle a
fait bouger toute la structure et là ça
a volé la totalité la serre qui s'envole
suite à la tempête c'est c'est pas
uniquement de l'argent qui s'envole
c'est l'outil de travail que Benoît
pratique tous les jours
qui s'envole donc ça veut dire des
récoltes décalées et une entreprise mise
en danger à la retraite de leurs parents
en 2018 Sébastien et Benoît Joseph
reprennent l'exploitation familiale et
décide dans diversifier la production
Benoît revient vivre à la ferme et se
lance dans le maraîchage bio en plus des
cultures
privé de serre il doit s'adapter
j'ai quand même lancé des tomates de
plein champ que j'avais pas prévu avant
pour avoir un peu de tomates cette à
l'automne et cet hiver dans la nuit
la perte est sèche pour financer son
remplacement les deux frères ont lancé
une cagnotte qui a déjà recueilli plus
de 7000 euros on a un emprunt de 18000
euros et on s'est dit mais on fait
comment pour financer cette deuxième
serre à nouveau 18000 euros sachant
qu'on a perdu la première on était donc
on a appelé notre banque pour faire une
simulation d'emprunt donc on attend le
retour de la banque
et en parallèle de ça on s'est dit
pourquoi on ferait pas un financement
participatif les contributions à la
cagnotte sont assorties de cadeaux les
donateurs les plus généreux seront
invités à manger et passer la nuit à la
ferme